It might be odd to get your head around, but
galaxies can and do collide.
But far from an wild party of death, galaxies
collisions yield hotbeds for new star formation,
leading astronomers to suspect that this not-so-violent
event is actually a driving factor behind
galactic evolution.
The big question here is how can galaxies
collide and not just destroy everything?
It helps to think about what a galaxy really
is.
Every galaxy is made up of some 100 billion
stars with planets orbiting their host stars,
but those stars are really far apart.
Take the Milky Way for example.
We’re about here on the edge of a spiral
arm called Orion Spur.
It looks crowded in our little neighborhood,
but our nearest neighbor Alpha Centuri A,
is actually 4.3 light years away.
So galaxies might full of stars, but those
stars are really far apart, meaning the likelihood
of two hitting is pretty low.
But that doesn’t mean nothing happens, because
there is stuff in those vast distances.
The “space” between stars is actually
full of gas and dust.
Within these regions are dense pockets of
interstellar material, called molecular clouds,
that collapse under their own mass and gravity,
forming protostars and eventually new stars.
When galaxies collide, it’s this material
— the interstellar gas and dust — that
interacts gravitationally with some neat results.
In a collision, one galaxy can rip material
from another, disrupting star formation and
adding more material to its own molecular
clouds.
A direct collision between these gases can
also result in shockwaves reverberating through
both galaxies, triggering new regions of star
formation where there wasn’t any before.
Aside from generating new pockets of star
formation, both close passes and full-on collisions
cause gravitational interactions begetting
interesting changes, causing spiral arms,
tidal tails, and even rings.
Two spiral galaxies could merge and form an
elliptical galaxy with more active star formation
than either had before.
But it’s not like this happens overnight…
not that there’s a “night” where galaxies
are concerned.
This process can take millions of years.
Which is a good thing because our own Milky
Way is on a crash course with the Andromeda
galaxy, but we’ve got a good 4 billion years…
That should be enough time to live my best
life.
If you want more cosmic science in your feed
be sure to subscribe to Seeker.
And if you want to know what happens when
galaxies die, Trace has more on that right
here.
You know what’d be awesome?
If after the Andromeda collision our sky lit
up with tons of newly forming stars!